In credential guesses?
A fairly good example,
right?
Will it really be replicable elsewhere
in the world?
It's the success of North America.
Is that going to happen in China and
South America and maybe in more modest
form here that's not very certain.
Look at the Bolus Ebay,
I'll say public debate about fracking.
People don't really sure,
right?
Why should we do that?
But if uncle venture guests is
successful at re doubles the previous
thought resource base of gas and then it
really makes it a real game changer.
You can really go for different types of
energy systems in a sense that you can
early gains replace coal by guests,
but Su built an big infrastructure
system,
uh,
on guests.
Also,
you start opening up options for the
future.
I will call and say you have room to
maneuver in 2020s,
2030s because you haven't guests
infrastructure,
which is also easily as they'll ask
extra cost.
They make suitable for hydrogen gas or
liquid hydrogen.
So actually my count,
you're lucky because you have an
infrastructure you can piggy back on.
If you do another roots,
then you don't have the infrastructure.
And then it becomes very expensive to
introduce hydrogen.